[Applaudissements]
j'ai un ami qui a inventé cette très
belle phrase le hasard n'existe pas s'il
existe il ne ressemble dans le point de
cette semaine qui est sorti mercredi au
lieu de jeudi
je trouve à la page 14 une phrase qui
mettait décidé et qui vous était destiné
cartésianisme et créativité sont deux
caractéristiques française dont
l'alliage peut donner le meilleur métal
éducatif
d'après vous qui a écrit cette phrase à
droite trois réponses pas du tout dans
un écrit paroles pointent un certain
jean michel blanquer
et c'est quand blanc caire était
directeur de l'enseignement secondaire
que j'ai eu la chance de collaborer avec
l'éducation nationale pendant trois ans
pour lancer un modèle de créativité pour
le secondaire le ministre a changé mais
elle n'a pas osé détruits ou bloquées et
de ce modèle continue encore grâce à
internet
ça c'était au jeu à temps je rentre dans
mon atelier première phrase qui a déjà
été dit c'est qui vous sera répétée vous
êtes tous créatif il n'existe pas de
personnes non créative et ça vous pouvez
l'observer en voyant des bébés tout ce
qu'ils apprennent ils inventent il
invente entre l otan et si vous avez la
chance d'avoir dans notre entourage ou à
l'occasion d'un voyage raza des bébés de
qui parle pas encore de moins d'un an
entré en communication avec eux et vous
serez un tout petit peu de patience
émerveillé de voir comme ils comprennent
tout ce que vous leur dites et même
davantage et même les concepts donc nous
grandissons en inventant et ça continue
jusqu'à ce que les parents animés de
bonnes intentions ne cherche à nous
former et fort mais c'est un verbe
horrible s'agissant d'êtres humains ça
veut dire mettre en forme
historiquement c'était parfaitement
justifiée la société avait une certaine
structure et pour qu'elle continue à
vivre et que les gens dedans puisse
tenir leur place
il fallait former le masson formelle
domestique formelle agents formés le
bandit et formés le ministre et ça a
bien marché jusque je suis qui lie
jusqu'à une vingtaine d'années nous
sommes entrés dans la société liquide
l'expression est un et d'un sociologue
américain qui est mort il ya deux mois
elle dit très bien ce qu'elle veut dire
dans la société se liguent chose est et
ce qu'elle sait un ministre un président
était quelqu'un qui savait gouverner
c'était clair un chef d'entreprise était
le chef qui savait ce qu'il fallait
faire pour que c'est l'entreprise
prospère
si vous regardez le catalogue des chefs
d'entreprise français
parmi eux vous trouvez moins de dix vrai
chef d'entreprise
les autres sont là parce qu'ils ont les
diplômes qu'il fallait parce qu'ils ont
suivi le cursus et et ça se propage et
ça continue sur cette même forme
mon métier c'est d'intervenir dans les
entreprises quand elles le veulent pour
mettre en place un système d'innovation
areva a été
nos principaux clients après nos
premières interventions nous avons formé
plus de 80 animateurs maison dont la
mission était d'animer des groupes
créatif leurs données première formation
et tout le matériel
et puis pratiquer des séances de pensée
créative dans lesquels on installe
quelques règles du jeu très simple on en
fait une affiche les bons interdit par
exemple tous jamais qu'est ce qui encore
comme phrase définitive
vous les connaissez vous les entendez
peut-être que voulait prononcé aussi qui
sont autant de murs qui me bloque le
flux créatif et ça a été l'intuition
géniale d'un publicitaire américain dont
vous avez peut-être entendu le nom alex
osbourne l'inventaire de brainstorming
il était président d'une des principales
agences de publicité américaine qui
existe toujours des vidéos au 7e round
et les le travail de l'agencé visiter
trouver des idées originales pour les
clients idée de campagne d idée d'
affiches et lui ne se résigner pas avoir
que dans les séances de travail majorité
des interventions étaient de type
critique et négatifs alors ils achètent
intuition suivant génial de couper la
séance en deux mi temps de 45 minutes
chacun première mi temps interdit
d'interdire
interdit de critiquer interdit de juger
interdit de dire c'est bien c'est
formidable le jugement est complètement
suspendu et en 45 minutes
un groupe motivé entraîneur peut arriver
à produire jusqu'à cette idée
fin de la première mi temps on examine
les idées qu'on a produit et si en a
cinq sur l'a36 on a une qui correspond à
tous les critères c'est gagné et on peut
passer à la partie suivante alors ça
s'applique bien à la publicité sur des
problèmes plus complexes comme inventer
des nouvelles machines des nouvelles
autos beaucoup travailler pour renault
inventée à nous voyons beaucoup
travaillé pour donald ça ne suffit pas
et nous avons donc un peu raffiné le
processus en cinq étapes que nous avons
appelée pape ça fait un come perception
hahaha com et comme analyse puis de
comme production s comme sélections et a
comme application actions et chacune de
ces étapes obéit à la même dialectique
que j'écrive décrivez tout à l'heure
c'est à dire une première étape appelée
divergentes
un triangle renversé où il est interdit
d'interdire toutes les idées sont
acceptés avec le sourire et on passe
ensuite à la phase convergentes on
examine ce qu'on a produit pour ge est
ce dont on n'a pas besoin et on avance
prom étape de perception parce que on
sait maintenant que nous n'utilisons que
très peu de personnes très rarement
utilise tout leur sens
or pour comprendre une réalité il faut
se l'approprier complètement non
seulement entendre son nom et ça c'est
très très cerveau gauche je pense que
vous a parlé de la dissymétrie cérébrale
oui non oui dans non oui huit fruits
il ya un prix nobel un homme qui a
découvert que le deux hémisphères
cérébraux fonctionne comme si c'étaient
deux cerveaux différents l'hémisphère
gauche
on pourrait l'appeler en schématisant un
peu l'hémisphère rationnelle travail
avec avec des mots et qu'il assemble
selon des phrases des deux types
déductif tandis que l'hémisphère droit
fonctionne à partir d'image de
sensations qui l'a assemble selon les
logiques du rêve
petite parenthèse la logique onirique la
logique du rêve est une des plus riches
pour découvrir des idées complètement
neuf donc les séances créative doivent
se passer dans des lieux très protégé on
ne risque pas d'être dérangé et la
technique du rêve éveillé dirige et qui
étaient inventées par des psychologues
suisse en particulier au maire de soual
va très loin et je garde un souvenir
encore ému d'un travail qu'on a fait en
trois jours pour un groupe de compagnies
d'assurances dans plusieurs pays où le
directeur monde n'arrivait pas à
déboucher sur une politique commerciale
qui soit complètement adopté par tous
les pays où cette compagnie d'assurance
travail alors c'était un séminaire de
trois jours à la campagne bien entendu
travail de jour travail après d'idées et
après le dîner du deuxième soir je sens
que le groupe est assez mûre est
installé dans la salle genre devant de
fermer les yeux et je les guide dans un
rêve
un rêve on va d'abord se promener on
chacun dans la nature qui veut dans la
forêt dans la plaine
et puis petit à petit je les ramène au
problème sur lequel on travaille qu'on
avait décortiqué pendant les deux
premières journées et je leur demande de
rêver à la solution puis quand le rêve
est terminé genre demande d'écrire leurs
conclusions
et puis de les lire et là c'était un
moment extraordinaire parce qu'ils
étaient tous arrivés à la même
conclusion puissante original et le
directeur général mans n'en revenais pas
alors je veux pas rentrer là dedans pour
le dire qu'une des choses qui me plaît
dans mon métier et je fais parfois des
interventions gratuites sur déçu des
entreprises sans but lucratif qui
pourraient pas se payer les honoraires
c'est calme mon travail me permet de
constater que les crétins et les
ça existe mais qui sont extrêmement
rares les gens se comportent comme des
imbéciles comme des crapules dans
certaines situations
ils savent pas s'en sortir autrement
mais si on arrive à créer le climat
positif et constructif qui est
nécessaire si je cherche dans toutes mes
relations
j'ai du mal cité deux ou trois noms qui
correspondrait à ces deux catégories
odieuse dont on les chariots prétendent
qu'ils sont de plus en plus nombreux et
qui seront peut-être une majorité donc
là la pratique créative nécessite en
amont est produit en aval une
orientation positive 2
énergie car la performance créative
s'obtient en agissant manière synchrone
sur trois facteurs le talent tout à
l'heure elle nous a lancé ce message et
vous l'avez accepté
vous êtes créatif si vous cherchez dans
votre passé de votre naissance
aujourd'hui vous trouverez des
situations vous avez fait preuve d'une
créativité extraordinaire
et comme certains prétendent que le
modestie est une qualité
ce fut vrai ce n'est plus aujourd'hui
vous avez tendance à oublier mais vous
êtes créatif et cette crête est une
autre chose
une découverte récente des neurosciences
font presque chaque semaine des
découvertes extraordinaires
c'est la découverte de mémoire totale
nous n'oublions rien toutes les
informations que nous avons créé
accueillie même inconsciemment elles
sont stockées donc pour mémoire c'est de
retrouver la formation dont on a besoin
au moment où on a besoin
donc si on arrive à activer ses
ressources cérébrale on les focalisant
suite et on trouve des solutions dans
les dizaines centaines d'interventions
que nous avons conduite avec mes
collaborateurs dans des entreprises de
toutes tailles et de plusieurs pays
n'avons pas vu un seul cas où on est pas
trouvé la solution
nous avons vu des cas où la solution n'a
pas été appliquée parce que actuellement
malheureusement et ça ne change pas
tellement les principaux ennemis de
l'innovation de la créativité dans les
entreprises dans l'état ce sont les
sommets nous sommes les victimes d'un
système hiérarchique hérité de saint
paul un très beau livre s'appelle
l'inversion du christianisme qui montre
comment notre modèle de société est une
reproduction à l'identique des modèles
de l'église catholique où il ya le pape
tout puissant ne pas contredire
les archevêques les évêques les prêtres
et les fidèles qui ont le droit de dire
amen
et malheureusement pour des raisons des
tas de raisons mais vous pouvez
l'imaginer les sommets
même quand ils font des discours c'est
l'innovation n'ont pas envie que ça
chose changement leur fait peur et ça
sera une de vos missions quand vous
serez cadres dans ces entreprises que
des rassurer et trouver des chemins
détournés pour l'innovation se
produisent malgré eux alors qu'ils
donnent des consignes d'innovation ce
que je dis ici mon temps est terminé
c'est que votre tâche est double d'une
part re découvrir et développer votre
créativité
si vous allez sur internet vous trouvez
une ample bibliographie en allant sur le
nom jaoui et puis une fois sur place
savoir que notre mission est double
direct pour trouver les idées dans votre
entreprise a besoin et les faire
appliquer et ensuite continuer à
entretenir en permanence votre
créativité mais je vais terminer par un
clin d'oeil
ja oui c'est un mot arabe et c'est au
cours d'un voyage l'intervention au
maroc que j'ai découvert que c'était
aussi un nom commun le jeu oui c'est une
plante une plante que vous pouvez
acheter même dans les souks même même à
paris est la caractéristique magique
deux caractéristiques quand on l'a fait
brûler elle chasse les mauvais esprits
donc si dans un lieu des choses se
passent mal mauvaise humeur une
catastrophe et s'est brûlé un peu de
jarvis moins cher que me brunet moi même
et les mauvais esprits disparaissent
deuxième application plus extraordinaire
encore
ça peut agir sur les femmes stériles
la recette se faire brûler déjà vides
dans un récipient qui est posée par
terre comme ici elle ne porte une très
longue jupe l'est pas de culotte elle
reste au dessus et quant à elles sont
imprégnées des vapeurs de jamie elles
deviennent ses commandes
voilà mon message
[Applaudissements]